follow to a story we first brought you
last month when a driver crashed into
stairs at an apartment complex on
washington near bruce
families not able to get in and out of
their homes safely
today jomola reports the stairs have
been replaced he joins us live
when can tenants finally move back in
joe
we were the first to share the story and
a lot of people were shocked by it even
some eight news now viewers came forward
to
actually help these people out but take
a live look here this evening stairs are
actually being worked on they were
knocked off of this building back
on february 14 when a car crashed into
them residents soon could be back home
it's like inconvenient for me right now
david goies and his family have been
living in a downtown hotel since they
left this apartment building a month ago
he says costs are adding up we like
home-cooked meals
and it's quite expensive to be eating
out very expensive
he hopes this as their last weekend in a
hotel
tenants contacted eight news now after
they were forced to use a ladder and a
chain to get upstairs
it was just something that i had to do
tracy sables saw my story she put up the
family in a hotel for a few weeks
but when that ran out goys used his
unemployment check she
heard they were still in a hotel so she
drove from boulder city to downtown las
vegas to pay for a few more nights
i'm really disappointed i'm disappointed
in
the way humanity has become
i believe in human kindness and that's
hopefully it'll kind of catch on you
know
the stairs appear to be days away from
being done these are photos taken by a
tenant
goys says the landlord told him the city
will be by on monday to inspect the new
stairs
they hope to move back next week to
settle down relax
and you know i'm eager to go back but
to keep that financially on my feet
now back out here live we're taking
another look at the the work being done
here on this building the other tenants
who live here are living elsewhere while
these repairs are being finished as well
and sable
did set up a gofundme link to help these
tenants out and to set up costs that she
has
paid for for that hotel if you would
like to help you can find a link on that
on this story on eightnewsnow.com
reporting live here near downtown las
vegas joe muller 8 news now